esküvők ezek nagyobb volumenű ünnepek
itt már nagy
emberlétszámot mozgósítunk meg tehát ide
már tényleg amikor egy étterembe le kell
bonyolítsunk egy egy ilyen ünnepet mint
egy esküvő például akkor egyértelmű hogy
teljesen más annak az identitása
teljesen másképp kell te szervezzél és
bele tudunk ebbe annyi mindent
csempészni hogy tényleg igaz ünnep
legyen és mi szakácsokul és mi
vendéglátósokul mi azért vagyunk hogy az
az embereknek örömet szerezzünk a vendég
szeretetünkkel a finom ételeinkkel a
gyönyör
felszolgálásainkkal hányan vagyunk mi
toppon hányan vagyunk mi keményen talpon
és végezzük a munkánkat azért hogy az az
ember kényelmesen szeretettel ünnepelje
a saját rendezvényét